distinguishing programs underpinning
these installers
so
so can you hear me no
yeah
ah great
hi
so can you see
my presentation
yes
great
so first of all uh i would like to
apologize for not being able to present
it to the just the problems by documents
in the entrance to the u.s um
so
i will talk about it this is tolerance
and resistance
a
mostly influenza virus infection
is
just a
a phd student
in in
my lab
our main interest when we started the
project was a
to understand more about why different
individuals show a a distinct disease
outcome
and
we decided to do some design that will
provide us
information as much information as we
can so we started with sisy mice it's a
it's a collection of mice each of them
is an inbred strain and there each one
is a different strain and you can take
as many as you want from each train and
so it's be different from other projects
usually
in mice
that
most researchers are using only one
strain then with many strands we can see
the the variation in the population and
we did in vivo
influenza infection we did several time
points five time points and also the new
infection and we took
a many different clinical parameters and
also gene expression from the lungs
so it's different from a human studies
well the lung tissue is not available
and also we can take
early time points that are not available
in infections
in human studies
so overall we have about 250 samples
that were collected
and we worked with this data
so just uh about the clinical data so
for example we have the weight loss
weight loss is the
is very informative in in
in mice
um also the the measurements of the
breathing dysfunctions uh
title kinds the damage of the lungs the
syria and so on
and the messenger and april filing so
for example here we can see over time
points for the entire population we can
see increase in the variable then in the
weight loss breathing and the
tissue damage over time and if you focus
for example on
one specific
a time point for the weight loss for
example and here is in the right is the
extension for across all cc mouse
strains the weight loss we can see that
each strain has a different
a different
weight loss so for example some of the
strains here on the right they lose
almost 25 percent of the weight after
only four days
right so they're very very sensitive and
the others like the ones that are at the
left just
continue to gain weight although we know
that they are infected we see the virus
in them but they'll continue to gain
weight so we have this variation and
also the standard variation is quite
small so it's a it seems there's a
genetic effect
and the
clean data so we
we continue to work on this but one more
thing to say just
about this variation so first we can
look at the variation in the phenotype
in the clinical phenotype as the weight
loss but in addition i can compare the
tissue damage or the weight loss or any
other clinical phenotype here in the
y-axis
to the valor building
to the
quantity of the virus the concentration
of the virus in the lungs in the x-axis
and here each point here is a different
individual mouse
and what we can see is that there is a
wide variation for example hearing the
tissue damage in this area of the lung
for the same viral
burden so for the same amount of virus i
see very different levels of tissue
damage and this we call disease
tolerance meaning that for the same
to the same level of infection i see
different levels of susceptibility of
the host the ability of the host to to
mean to tolerate or to maintain the
health
under the same level of the virus so we
see both levels of variation both in the
clinical data itself and also in the
relations between the health and the in
the viral burden the disease tolerance
so we'll start satisfied with this
because
this opens
the possibility that we can see the
maybe the molecular basis for a
for this variation
um okay so now i'm just
briefly
talk about our approach
so the first thing that we did is to do
dimension reduction
uh there is two options to do the
dimension reduction either to reduce the
dimensionality of the individuals or to
reduce the dimensionality of
the genes
and i'm focusing now only on the gene
explanator just the gene expression data
from the 250 individuals so i'm taking
all individuals from all time points
together from all strands together
everything together just a considerate
inspiration and we did the mention
reduction
so that
in here in the two-dimensional
map
each point is a gene after we consider
all the data together we use the
autoencoder neural network but it can be
also
other ways to do dimension reduction
this works the best uh so the final map
that we have is a map of the similarity
rule it's a dimensional reduction uh so
each two genes
the same may be very similar behavior
across all time points and across all
stress strains or all mouse strains so
they're really similar in many aspects
not only in specific strain or in
specific time points
so now the next step is just to look in
each specific individual here
each map is one specific individual and
we the positions of the map are the same
always we just color coding the
measurements of each individual in its
own map and we see that some individuals
if
for example here individual number one
the direction is to the
a top left from a blue to red and for
this individual three at the right here
we see the direction from the
bottom left to the top right so each one
is a different overall state in this map
so to analyze this quantitatively
we did the convolution in order to get
the the state of each individual on the
y-axis and on the x-axis and this is the
map in the right here
we have in the x-axis and in the y-axis
we see the states with the convolved
states based on this map of each
individual so each individual is a point
and for example individual three
the direction for both the x and y axis
is positive so we say it in the positive
a positive in both the x and y axis
uh we call this a two axis is t
and r for the x and y axis and i will
explain shortly why we did it so it's
the t level and the r level of each
individually just two scores for each
individual based on the dimension
reduction
actually we could do the opposite
maybe we could do the opposite just to
reduce the dimension first to get the
map of the individuals and then to
create the map of the genes but it's not
a linear dimension reduction and we
don't get the same results
okay only if we first reduce the
dimension of the genes and then
the
dimension of the
of the states of the individuals we get
this
dissolution
so
what's special about this work is that
we spent a lot of time time in trying to
understand what are these two access to
main access because we saw and i did not
follow it here but we saw that um
the two access explained a very large of
a
percentage of the variation it's very
similar
similarly explain a
large percentage of the variations so
they should be very interesting for for
infections
so just to go to um
to what
maybe essentially we got so first both
of these
levels t and r levels across the
population are increasing during
infection see them almost always
increasing together during infection
most of them are increasing in many
different infections that we tested also
increasing in wound healing
but if we look at
maybe the trivial splits that we could
think about for example if maybe one of
them is in it and the other is adaptive
or maybe one of them is pro inflammation
and the other is anti-inflammation but
in all different aspects that are known
we saw that
both of them are the same so it was not
a trivial explanation for these
two
distinct programs
so we thought maybe it will be would be
related to resistance and disease
tolerance i mentioned it briefly i'll
explain it again
a
just a resistance is a program of a
pathogen elimination just
the molecular program that finds to
eliminate fights to eliminate the
pathogen and the disease tolerance is a
it's more a physiological property
of the
the maintenance of the health in the
presence of a pathogen
um so it's the relationship between the
health and the
amount of the virus okay here the
pathogen so that's this is tolerance and
this is tolerance
is not a defi first it's not immune
tolerance the lack of responsive
responsiveness to antigen it's a
different it's disease tolerance
and
it's not
molecularly just defined physiologically
by the relations between the two
physiological parameters in the
literature
and what we've shown
is that
we
we have three reasons to believe
that a program r the first program the
y-axis is related to resistance ability
the ability of those to eliminate a
protogen pathogen and a program t is
related or associated with disease
tolerance the ability to maintain health
in the presence of the pathogen
so i'll start with the first evidence
we need functional analysis so for
example here the map each point here is
an individual and we can
do color coding by the level of specific
genes for example rock one or graph one
and we see some directions it's
endotypes based on specific genes
so based on this map we can
we can characterize each gene
for its relations with the t program and
the r program for example rock one is
negative correlated with the x axis
which is the t program so it's
negatively correlated with the t program
and so on so based on these associations
of each gene with the t and l programs
we can do functional analysis and this
is the results of the functional
analysis
for in the y-axis it's the
enrichments
a functional enrichment in program r
x-axis is function enrichments in
program t
and surprisingly what we saw that for
program r we see many functions related
to resistance for example cytokine
storms prr signaling antigen
presentation all of them are against the
pathogen but when we look at the x-axis
in the enrichment in the program t
we see wondering and ecm and geogenesis
many functions related to maintaining
the health of the host it's not against
the vowels
for the health of the horse
so that's the first evidence a
contributing to the idea that that's
disease tolerance and not
a resistance the t
program
uh now for evidence too evidence still
relates
to the physiological phenotype because
disease tolerance and resistance are
actually
a defined er at the physiological level
or previously well defined at the
physiological level
um so we correlated the and r level with
the viral burden and also with the
relationships between the host health
and the amount of the virus which is the
disease tolerance
signature at the physiological level and
what we saw that the other levels are
correlated with the barrel burden that's
a signature or mark of resistance
but the typical
correlated with the disease tolerance
phenotype
the ratio of tissue damage to the barrel
building
um so
we have the
at the
phenotypic level across the the heart we
see the almonds of resistance and the
almost of the tolerance for the average
labels respectively
and the third evidence is just that we
took a
many many functional classes of response
to different stress different types of
stress
so we splitted them into biotic stress
and abiotic stress if it's any if it's
any kind of pathogen it's biotic stress
and otherwise it's abiotic stress
and then we do a and again enrichment
analysis and we see that for the x-axis
which is the program t we see
association with um
with biotic and abiotic stress in here
in two colors but for the program r the
resistance program we see associations
only with the biotic stress and this is
according accordance
in accordance with the
general understanding that if it's to
maintain the health you need it both for
biotic and abiotic stress but if it's to
fight against a pathogen you need it
only for the resistance
a program
so this also supports based on a
analysis across many different types of
stress that we see
indeed the
the program to maintain health during
infection and the program to resist
against their virals
so um we did it in bulk dish market
back lungs but then we tested it in many
different other data sets we see the
same signatures but prospectively in
bronze epithelial cells in human and
many other immune cell types
uh inhuman individuals across court so
we see the same signatures if we we know
what to look
when we see the signatures so we think
that it's a
first it's intracellular autonomous
states it's not only at the level of the
back tissue and we think that it's both
for immune cells and non-immune cells
both in it and adaptive immune cells so
the general progress uh just like the
for example prrs and taylor signaling is
the general problems interferon
signaling is a general also the split
for these two problems is is a general a
split between two distinct states in
response to infection usually responding
together but since
we're different genetic backgrounds
we did a
we did
could use the fact that they are not
always synchronized completely and then
we could split them
um so just briefly uh i will mention
here that we did a lot of experimental
work
uh what we did is to do associations of
genes to each of these programs across
many different data sets infections and
autoimmune disease to see which of the
specific genes that most correlated with
each of these programs and this you see
the ranking
for the t and our programs and for the
for the resistance it's easy we found
the top the top ranked ones were just
many of them just interferon signaling
and genes that are known to be a
validated iv restriction factor so 16
factors to influenza so it makes sense
but for the x-axis it's it's less
defined because usually today the
disease tolerance is not defined at the
molecular level so there are no no way
known regulators of disease tolerance so
we saw these two ones that the guardian
mape 2k2 that seems very strong one we
chose the arghardia and we validated i
did not show it here but we validated
that
in vito that if we do perturbation for
gadia we protect specifically the tea
program not the art program both for our
overexpression
and for
a perturbation of it and also we affect
the disease tolerance phenotype so
meaning the ratio between the cell death
and the amount of the biosphere per cell
is so that's for a validation or maybe
potato
regulator
a
for the disease tolerance
um
and also if we
try if we're trying to see if these
programs can predict
a phenotypic diversity so we look at the
levels of the tnr programs before
infection and then
we look at different phenotypes of
severity of infection of course after
the infection so the relationship
relationship relationships between the t
levels before the infection and the
disease phenotype
and
came very strong for the systemized for
examples we see the t levels before
infection in lungs correlated with the
severity of infection
then we validated this also in another
court of mice the bxp code
that's published data it's the same
results and also in human blood if you
take macrophages in human blood blood
um tea levels against the severity of
infection again we see the same
relationships and we don't see these
relationships with the resistant program
so we we think that disease tolerance
have an effect specific effect on the
severity of infection
rather than assistance which is might be
quite surprising
um
so this paper is already in the
bioarchive
uh and the
gal no fear led this project together
with our collaborator and many others
helped with this interpretation
including freud iraqi
uh
for the sisy mice
for the interpretation of the results
so
thank you all for your attention and i
will be glad to take the questions
so um it's very interesting and i was
wondering uh if you've been um
thinking about you know how
this this is tolerance versus
in our response
could affect people's response to
immunization we see that sometimes
people are immunized they have really
strong response
while others you know might not feel
anything so would that
distinction
be predictive of the response to
immunization
yes
um that's a great question so we thought
the same we just started the
collaboration
to investigate
actually trained immunity
just
what would be the long-term consequence
of a
of the vaccination and we do it
with yellow fever virus and with bcg
specifically
so we don't know we just
started now okay so we've been thinking
about it very nice yeah yeah we started
we collected the data and we started to
to investigate this
because because you need you know enough
individuals and to to have control data
to investigate this
fire it's great talk can you go back to
the slide where you have this human
example yeah one more yeah so water
no no
this one this one yeah so in the human
patient what what do the points mean
in the left it looks like they mean
individual mice but on the left
what what do they mean
can you repeat the question what left
what do we see on the on the human
patient example on the right what are
what what is the meaning
point
that we see okay
so
this this uh data set is gene expression
data set it's a very large data set in
which they took
a blood of individuals at the beginning
of the winter
uh and before any infection in the
winter and then if they were sick they
came and then they tested if they had
influenza then they they took gene
expression after
during disease
uh so what we had is two days uh post
symptoms here
the and also the the
the blood gene expression before
infection about three months before the
infection that's what we have here it's
not just at the beginning of the
infection and
so for the and they did the macrophages
so we for the x-axis we calculated t
level uh
for the blood mfs and for the y-axis we
didn't have clinical data for these
individuals so it took only the r level
it's today's post symptoms because we
know that the r level is correlated very
well with the amount of the vowels for
example and here it just shows the
amount of the values but actually if i
look in all other symptoms
in mice we see that very good
correlations with the other levels
uh and the symptoms so we know that it's
a good indication our level for a for
the
severity of disease
okay thanks
anyone else
okay thank you
wonderful thank